Andrew Tate got into a little Twitter
squabble with Greta hunberg now you all
know Greta thundberg she is the young
lady who believes that the Earth is
going to end any minute now and has
become a hero of the machine and the
world economic forum and all of those
things uh they got into a little bit of
a Twitter spat so here is the tweet that
started this thing by Andrew Tate he
wrote hello Greta thundberg I have 33
cars my Bugatti has a quad turbo my two
Ferrari 812 competazion is that a word
have that's an Italian word I think have
v12s this is just the start please
provide your email address so I can send
a complete list of my car collection and
their respective enormous emissions now
he's obviously playing a bit of a troll
here he's throwing this at her like hey
I'm a dude producing something in the
world I've got a lot of stuff and he's
bragging about it and he doesn't want
her taking his cars uh Greta then
responded and said yes please do
enlighten me email me at small dick
energy at getalife.com and that got over
a million likes because people are what
they are anyway why am I telling you
about this a little spat between a
kickboxer and this little climate
activist well then uh two days later
bizarrely Andrew Tate was arrested in
Romania we've got a little video here
all right and for a little context on
that we've got more from the daily wire
American British media personality and
former kickboxer Andrew Tate and his
brother were detained in Romania in a
human trafficking investigation Thursday
along with a former policewoman
according to reports Romanian
authorities allegedly detained Tate and
his brother at their luxury Villa after
armed police raided his residence
searching for evidence related to the
case in which the brothers are accused
of abducting two women authorities
reportedly detained the two brothers for
24 hours Tates reported apprehension
comes after a day after he filmed a
video criticizing climate activist Greta
thundberg which included a pizza box
from a national chain in Romania Tate
faced allegations of human trafficking
in Romania in April 2022 however Tate
reportedly said the accusations stemmed
from a swatting incident where
authorities accused him and his brother
of obtaining large sums of money with
which they bought houses luxury cars and
cryptocurrencies according to reports
okay so I'm just piecing something
together here that I don't know exactly
what's going on here but it does strike
me as a little odd that this guy who is
becoming internet sensei Nation gets
into a fight with the protected child of
the climate movement and then literally
two days later he is arrested in Romania
Greta thundberg was gloating about it on
the Twitter she said this is what
happens when you don't recycle your
pizza boxes now there was this rumor
that he was arrested purely because he
had sort of doxed himself because the
pizza chain is in Romania that rumor
flew like wildfire I mean it spread
crazy all over the internet turned out
not to be true of course in many many
mainstream people from NBC and elsewhere
were tweeting it but we thought it would
be funny to throw back to a little
something about Greta there is a way to
deal with Greta you don't have to show
off all your cars to deal with Greta you
know the best way to deal with Greta is
you just ignore her cue Donald Trump
thank you very much
how dare you